the winter olympics are right around the
corner here are five things you need to
know
[Music]
number one the sports there are seven
new events at beijing 2022 women's
monobab big air freestyle skiing mixed
teams and short track speed skating
relay ski jumping freestyle ski aerials
and snowboard cross maybe you've caught
on but there are more mixed events
that's how the ioc is promoting greater
gender diversity number two robots lots
and lots of them at the main press
center food is prepared and served by
robot chefs and the dishes get delivered
to tables from an overhead grid to
mitigate the spread of cobid we can
expect to see way more in action there's
a logistics robot for contactless
deliveries and of course virus fighting
robots that roam around with
disinfectant number three the boycott
you may have heard about it the u.s uk
australia canada and denmark are among
the countries staging a diplomatic
boycott over concerns about china's poor
human rights record that means they
won't be sending any political delegates
to beijing but athletes will still
compete in one of the biggest sporting
events in the world
number four the bubble aka the
battleground between china's zero covid
policy and the infectious omicron
variant the closed loop will cover
stadiums venues accommodations and
ceremonies all to keep distance away
from the public and the internet well
within the loop beijing has promised
access to partially unrestricted
internet access dropping the great
firewall that normally blocks services
like facebook and youtube number five
last but not least the athletes from
legends like shaun white uzuru hanyu and
chloe kim to up and coming stars like
eileen goo and matt bae mishkoff they'll
all be there to get their hands on the
gold and hopefully get back home safe
and sound
[Music]